the movie's premise is set in a
dystopian society about 200 years in the
future the earth is in a dilapidated
state with high pollution levels and
limited resources the majority of the
water sources are contaminated food is a
rare commodity and the air's oxygen
levels are incredibly low many years ago
a group of humans were sent to the moon
alongside an artificial intelligence
system called io to create a more
livable society and develop useful
technology to help save the earth after
three generations the humans on the moon
successfully established a grandiose
society inhabitable by humans and full
of resources named moonhaven they
started living a good life while the
people on earth still suffered from the
planet's terrible conditions on a cold
night in moonhaven a girl named chill
steals and runs away with a peculiar
device however she is soon caught and
killed by her lover strego who then
retrieves it from her the following
morning a pair of patrolling police
officers named arlo and paul find the
body of a murdered woman in an open
field using an advanced tracking gadget
they identify her as chill span the
woman from earlier they are shocked by
the incident as this is the first murder
that has ever happened on moonhaven soon
the duo heads out to search for the
killer this doesn't take long though as
they arrest and imprison strigo shortly
after however when the officers visit
his cell for questioning he attacks one
of them and immediately makes a run for
it next we are introduced to the
protagonist bella sway an experienced
pilot who has been tasked to transport
indira mayor the envoy of io and a
high-ranking official on earth alongside
her bodyguard tom to the moon for an
executive visit before they commence
their journey tom engages bella in a
little chat breaking the ice as the two
get friendly soon indira arrives and the
trio embark on their journey to the moon
on the ship bella receives a call from
jt a friend of hers on earth who asks
her to smuggle a psychedelic drug named
singer from the moon back to the earth
at first she is skeptical but when jt
insists she agrees in the next scene the
aircraft finally lands on the moon after
a long trip bella remains on the
aircraft while indira accompanied by tom
heads out for a meeting with the council
chair maita the ruler of the moon's
human society about an hour later bella
spots a bird which nose dives into a
surrounding lake dropping off a package
she retrieves the package and takes it
inside the spaceship on opening it she
finds the singer which she was tasked to
smuggle to earth just as she puts the
package in a hidden drawer bella sees
two policemen knocking on the aircraft's
doors curious to find out what they want
she opens it letting them in the
officers turn out to be the same ones
that found chill's body and they have
come to bring her in for questioning
bella is confused as to why she's being
asked to come along with them but she
obliges nonetheless on getting to their
quaint precinct she learns that her
sister chill was murdered the day before
however the news doesn't phase bella as
she didn't even know of her sister's
existence because her mother left for
the moon right after bella's birth in
the following scene bella is taken by
paul to see chill's adoptive sister asus
asus had witnessed her sister's murder
and requested to see bella to pass a
message to her on her arrival asus tells
her about her mother and sister before
informing paul that there was a second
witness besides her at the crime scene
on hearing this paul and bella revisit
the scene to look for clues there they
spot a figure watching them from the
woods the duo swiftly runs after the
stalker soon they reach a wall
demarcating the livable human conducive
area from the rest of the moon despite
paul's warnings bella goes past it
crawling through a nearby hole in
pursuit of the stalker however when she
gets outside she instantly feels
light-headed and doesn't go far before
collapsing due to the lack of oxygen in
the area when she wakes up she finds
herself in an unfamiliar house on
investigating she finds paul and his
family having lunch at the dinner table
and proceeds to join them in the process
she learns a bit about their culture on
the moon such as their strange cuisines
as well as the various dances they offer
to bereaved families when it's her turn
she tells them about earth and how the
people are still living there in
dilapidated conditions elsewhere indira
is in a meeting with maita the council
chair indira informs her that io's
algorithm has proposed a change of
moonhaven's council authority despite
there being two years left in the
current administration's tenure maita
expresses her displeasure on hearing the
news citing that she has done nothing to
deserve the termination of her rule
indira agrees but reminds maita that io
is capable of making accurate
predictions of the future and advises
the councilwoman to quit before earth's
top officials take action in the
following scene bella who has returned
to the aircraft sees a system intruder
warning on her monitor when she goes to
investigate the source of the alert she
finds strego lurking in a corner and
quickly tases him however before she can
take definitive action she is
interrupted by tom who calls for her
from the other end of the aircraft bella
goes to meet him and there tom initiates
a random but wholesome conversation with
her a few minutes later strego also
enters the room and tells tom that his
project is done causing tom's
countenance to immediately change he
shoots strego instantly killing him and
soon after attacks bella the two begin
fighting and ultimately tom gets the
upper hand however in a desperate
attempt bella reaches for the singer and
manages to inject him with it thus
stunning and disarming him tom's about
to trip balls in the next scene a
frightened bella walks out of the
aircraft and runs into paul seeing bella
in a frightened state paul sedates her
causing the former to collapse on him
when she wakes up she finds herself in a
tent and instantly panics trying to find
an exit she pushes against one of its
sides and falls through landing in a
body of water it turns out that the tent
is isolated in a mighty sea meanwhile
indira who has long returned to the
space ship holds a virtual meeting with
the earth's council she informs them of
the recent happenings on the moon
including the murders of strego and
chill as well as the attack on tom the
council is furious at the turn of events
and speculates that drego was the one
who attacked tom which makes them
fearful that the mooners are turning
against them the fear is especially
aggravated as the first batch of mooners
is scheduled to return to earth to begin
its restoration process in less than a
couple weeks indira tries her best to
alleviate their fears assuring them that
she is in control of the situation but
the council is still skeptical later
that day paul takes a canoe to visit
bella when he enters the tent she
attacks him thinking he's there to harm
her however he explains that he only
brought her there to keep her safe
hearing this bella finally calms down
unsure of what happened last night paul
asks her about tom and strego
surprisingly bella lies to him as she is
scared to have him discover that she was
the one smuggling singer she tells him
that strego was the one who injected tom
with the drug paul senses that something
is amiss but decides to believe her
story anyway before he leaves he informs
her that tom is still alive and is
recuperating back at the ship thanks to
io in the meantime indira pays a visit
to mita's home there she firmly asks her
to relinquish her position and pass io's
key to the next council chair however
maita remains adamant about staying in
power and rejects her request elsewhere
we see that bella has made her way to
another tent several meters away from
the first she steals a canoe nearby and
paddles for over an hour before finally
reaching the shore in a bid to return to
her spaceship she runs around the forest
but soon gets lost and captured by the
mooners following this she is isolated
at the city station in a sleep-like
state coincidentally paul who is also at
the station uses their advanced
technology to search her mind and
watches some of her life experiences
specifically the war times in which she
served in the military as a pilot
however since he is not used to such
acts of violence he isn't able to keep
watching and turns the feet off then he
goes through her call records and finds
her conversation with jt thus confirming
that she is a smuggler immediately he
wakes her from the dreamlike state and
brings her in for thorough questioning
confronted with the damning evidence
bella comes clean on the smuggling but
maintains that she did not attack tom
with the singer upon hearing her
confession paul takes her to the moon
council for a trial to determine her
fate during the trial one council member
advocates that they put her back to
sleep state while another proposes they
send her back to earth where she belongs
however before they finalize on one of
the options paul steps forward and tells
the council about what he saw in her
memories he declares her a broken soul
reminding them that the role of mooners
is to save earth's souls like her with
this he suggests that the council let
her stay under his supervision instead
the council is moved by his words and
eventually sets bella free after the
trial paul now responsible for bella
takes her to his house there she finally
reveals everything and admits that she
was the one who injected tom with the
singer but clarifies that it was purely
in self-defense paul appreciates her
honesty even though it took three tries
to get there and hands her a bag
containing a wooden box which belonged
to her sister chill inside she finds a
collection of her mother's things
including a strange-looking projection
device when they switch it on they find
a pre-recorded message from chill
warning them that the mooners were never
going to save the earth she also
mentions that the bridge which is the
transport of the mooners to the earth is
a trap the message leaves the duo in awe
as they stare at the projection in
disbelief the following morning paul
visits his partner arlo in his house to
tell him about chill's ominous warning
from the recording paul panics at the
severity of the issue but arlo comforts
and reassures him that they will
eventually discover the truth when paul
leaves the house he finds a girl dressed
in officer's clothing waiting for him
outside she introduces herself as blue
his assigned apprentice and silently
tails him as he walks away meanwhile
bella goes to meet indira to inform her
that tom is a double agent who is in
cahoots with some mooner rebels trying
to sabotage the bridge she recounts what
happened on the night of the attack
explaining that tom tried to kill her
because she witnessed strego speaking to
him however indira does not believe her
declaring that tom would never betray
her right then we get a flashback to
indira's past at an io training facility
there a teenage indira meets another
student named basta the two girls
instantly hit it off and become best
friends their stay at the facility is
generally peaceful and quiet however one
day the facility is attacked by a group
of terrorists indira and basta enter a
hidden room to hide from the armed men
but are quickly discovered by one of
them much to endear a surprise basta
joins them and leaves revealing that she
is one of the terrorists back to the
present bella returns to her ship and
retrieves the package which the singer
was contained in she returns and shows
it to paul who analyzes the object but
can't seem to make much of it as it has
no distinct markings or symbols however
when she mentions that a bird delivered
it he immediately goes wide-eyed
realizing the source soon he takes her
to a craft shop where mooners construct
robotic delivery birds on entering the
shop bella spots a pelican-shaped design
identical to the one that delivered the
singer and stares at its craftsmen
suspiciously never trust someone who has
a thing for pelicans just then the man
sprints out of the shop and into a
nearby forest while bella quickly chases
him in hot pursuit with paul trailing
behind luckily after a bit of back and
forth they finally capture the runaway
craftsman cyril and bring him in for
questioning at the precinct they ask who
he's working with but cyril is
uncooperative and denies being involved
in a bid to bait him bella lies that tom
has woken up and would eventually spill
all the secrets of the moon or rebels
however cyril remains silent and is
eventually allowed to leave the precinct
when they realize that he won't budge as
he leaves paul asks blue to spy on him
just in case he does anything suspicious
later that day paul and bella engage in
a little argument over the intentions of
the mooners bella is certain that some
mooners are trying to sabotage the
bridge with the help of tom as they want
to keep the paradise they established
away from earth but paul who blindly
trusts his people does not see reason
and swears that the mooner would never
do that in the following scene maita and
indira enter the i o authorization
chamber the chamber permits access to
foreign aircraft to enter the moonhaven
and requires authorization from both
leaders without their unanimous consent
no ship can land in the haven maita and
indira initiate the authorization
process in anticipation of the arrival
of a fleet of aircraft which are to
convoy the first batch of mooners to the
earth however at the last authorization
stage maita has a change of heart and
withdraws her consent thus cancelling
the endorsement as she storms out of the
chamber giving indira no explanation
confused indira reports the matter to
the earth council who become even more
anxious over the situation as patience
is running thin on earth with humans
expecting the mooners to arrive soon to
recuperate the planet in the following
scene bella paul and his daughter elna
are walking through the woods when paul
receives a nearby distress signal from
blue they quickly trace the signal and
find her lying amongst some shrubs in
the forest she informs them that cyril
caught her stalking him in the woods and
then tried to kill her however she
fought back and luckily managed to knock
him out the group helps her up and after
this they trace cyril's footsteps to a
nearby cave in it they discover that
some mooners have removed their implants
which are small pebble-like trackers
that help io monitor each individual's
movements and activities hence making
them untraceable the group brainstorms
why they would do this and soon deduces
that cyril must have told them about
tom's recovery therefore they realize
that the mooners are planning to attack
tom wasting no time bella and paul
quickly head to indira's house
accompanied by a squad of officers to
protect tom who is still in a coma early
the next morning a masked mooner attacks
a guarding officer the episode ends as
the rest of the group slowly encircles
the house preparing for an ambush to see
what happens next watch the second part
in series recap